these sentencing remarks are being
translated
I will speak slowly to assist The
Interpreter
copies of these sentencing remarks will
however be made available to you and the
Press
Sebastian Kalinowski died on the 13th of
August 2021.
he was 15 years old
in the weeks before his death Sebastian
had been subjected to horrific physical
abuse
at the post-mortem examination he was
found to have sustained 23 rib fractures
there was a large blood clot in his
liver
his heart muscle was damaged
there was evidence of a muscle sharing
injury to his left thigh
there was a very large number of linear
scabs across his lower back and buttocks
the result of wounds to that area which
had been cut
forming sepsis and collapse
the uncontroverted medical evidence was
that in the few days before his death
the infection would have caused
Sebastian to have been very unwell
short of breath very weak
and obviously so
the jury did not need to speculate as to
who caused those injuries or how they
were inflicted
in late June of 2021 a closed circuit TV
system was set up in the house in Leeds
Road Huddersfield where you both lived
with Sebastian
you placed cameras in the living room
and in Sebastian's bedroom
after his death the hard drive was found
by the police where you had hidden it in
the table in the living room
whether or not that footage demonstrates
the full extent however of the abuse
that was meted out to Sebastian I do not
know
but it shows you latachevsky using your
martial arts techniques
punch and kick and knee Sebastian
repeatedly about the Torso and head
using Sebastian's body in the same way
as you used the punch bag which hung in
your garden
the footage shows you beating Sebastian
with a bed slat and an electric cable
over his lower back
sometimes you watch latachevsky as he
set about Sebastian
on other occasions you sat indifferently
on the sofa eating or drinking and
watching television
on many occasions you were an active
participant in the abuse you landed
blows on Sebastian too
you encouraged latachevsky by either
initiating or joining in the abuse by
slapping and punching Sebastian
on the 16th of June of this year so
during the course of this trial you both
pleaded guilty to the offense of Cruelty
to a child
on the 14th of July 2022 again during
the course of the trial latachevsky you
pleaded guilty to manslaughter
the 22nd of July the jury convicted you
both of Sebastian's murder
as for the plea to manslaughter this has
been superseded by the conviction for
murder I direct that it should lie on
the file and I make no order in respect
of that offense
all Council in the case agree that the
offense of murder and that of Cruelty
cannot in this case be differentiated
the cause of Sebastian's death was
infection in his ribs any or all of the
rib fractures were involved in the
process which ultimately led to his
death
I will impose a sentence in respect of
that offense which runs concurrently at
the same time as the ascendants for the
offense of murder and will reflect the
totality of your offending in the
sentence which I impose for the offense
of murder
for the offense of murder the sentence
is fixed by law it is life imprisonment
I must decide whether the murder of
Sebastian is a murder of such
exceptional seriousness that it requires
me to make a whole life order in
accordance with paragraph to have
scheduled 21 of the sentencing act 2020
or alternatively whether I should take a
minimum make a minimum term order
if the latter
there is no dispute but that the
starting point for that minimum term
order is 30 years before adjustment for
aggravating and mitigating factors
if I do impose a minimum term order then
it does not follow that either of you
will be released from prison at the
conclusion of that minimum term
you may never be released whether you
are will be a question for the parole
board in due course
in reaching my decision on this issue I
take into account the following facts of
which I'm sure
having been the trial judge in this case
Sebastian was born in 2006.
for the first four years of his life he
lived in Poland with you colonaska his
mother
in 2010 you came to England to live
where you quickly began a relationship
with latachevsky
you left Sebastian in the care of his
biological father
and during the ten years which followed
you saw him on three occasions
shortly before October 2020 Sebastian's
father contacted you to tell you that
Sebastian was getting into trouble with
the authorities in Poland
you and latachevsky went to Poland to
collect him
I accept that when he first came to
England to live with you both
your intention was to care for him
properly
he was enrolled at school
whereas teachers spoke highly of his
intelligence and his courtesy and he was
always impeccably turned out
any kindness however which you initially
showed Sebastian was short-lived
by as early as Christmas 2020 there were
signs that all was not going well
at a party you discussed with friends
your approach to punishing Sebastian for
obviously only Petty childish
misdemeanors
on the 18th of January of 2021 you
leftachevsky recorded footage
of you shouting and cursing at Sebastian
you referred to
costing around one hour recorded on that
same phone later in January we hear the
sounds of you latachevsky hitting
Sebastian
although the abuse takes place off
camera I have no doubt that what is
recorded on that phone is the sound of
you beating the souls of Sebastian's
feet with a broken spindle from the
staircase
we hear Sebastian shrieks in pain
we hear your torrent of vile insults as
you accuse Sebastian of lying
kalinoska you then covered up what had
happened by lying to the school over the
following few days
explaining that Sebastian couldn't come
to school because he had a fever
no doubt you were both worried that the
presence of bruising on Sebastian's body
or his injuries would have raised alarm
at school
I have no doubt that the abuse continued
between January 2021 and the timing of
the installation of the CCTV in June but
how severe and how often I cannot know
for sure
there is however an audio recording
available a view colonaska speaking to
latachevsky
during this period in which
ever
that the abuse appears to become more
frequent and far more serious
over the course of the three weeks
between school breaking up on the 23rd
of July and Sebastian's death on the
13th of August there is scarcely a day
that goes by
that Sebastian is not subjected to some
form of physical abuse
and I describe just four occasions upon
which Sebastian was abused
on the 30th of July CCTV shows Sebastian
performing squats and push-ups
this exercise punishment regime is
interrupted by you latachevsky striking
him on the back and the side of the head
you knee him and punch him in the chest
you both then delayed calling an
ambulance
by no later than 8 40 it must have been
obvious to you both that Sebastian was
dead or dying
you lot of chefsky appear to appreciate
the seriousness of the situation and
give CPR compressions and breaths
you colonoska do absolutely nothing
other than wander downstairs making sure
that the curtain is lowered on the
window in the back door
clean up the table and you take a drink
from a mug
at 9 26 the CCTV is disconnected and the
cameras ripped from the walls
you try and hide the hard drive in the
draw in the living room
ski telephone your work explaining that
you can't come in today as you have big
problems
no ambulance is called until 10 55.
when arrested by the police you both
lied
in this trial atachevsky or defense was
that your punishment of Sebastian which
you couldn't deny was reasonable
kalanowski you tell the jury that you
were coerced into going along with
latachevsky's abuse of Sebastian because
you were frightened and that you too
were the victim of his violence
anyone who has watched even part of the
CCTV footage of what took place in that
house last summer
could only be utterly horrified by what
they saw
and quite bewildered that anyone would
behave in this way towards a teenage boy
let alone one who should be a much loved
child or stepchild
it begs the question of why anyone would
behave in this way
this is a question that I have
considered myself
it's quite clear to me latachevsky that
by your physical abuse of Sebastian you
sought to demonstrate your control and
your dominance over him
you made him call you Mr anjay
you installed CCTV so that in your
paranoia you could make sure that
Sebastian was performing his punishment
exercises when you were not there
you are a bully
minor perceived misdemeanors or teenage
acts of defiance were dealt with by
extreme punishment
like all bullies doubtless unable to
obtain respect in any other way you
sought to intimidate and frighten
Sebastian who was weaker than you
and then Sebastian you found an easy
prey
you have no self-control
the CCTV footage shows you often flying
into a rage pacing the room with a
Grimace on your face as you scream at
Sebastian
there are times when viewing the footage
that it seemed to me that you had lost
awareness that you were actually hitting
a human being
and not your punch bag
between punches you would pause to
admire your physique and the Contour of
your muscles in the full length mirror
in the living room
as for you colinasco the explanation is
simple
you just did not care about Sebastian
you were only interested in yourself
the letter which you wrote the
latachevsky whilst on remand tells me
all that I need to know about your
relationship towards your son
in that letter which is lengthy you
write about yourself
you write about your relationship with
latachevsky and your continued love for
him telling him that you would happily
marry him even wearing a prison uniform
you're only real worry
was what had happened to your cat after
your arrest and where your cat had been
taken
in this very long letter there is not
one word about your son Sebastian
about his death and the loss of that
life
I've had the benefit of reading the
statement from Sebastian's father
by contrast he speaks movingly of his
sense of loss and his anger
understandable anger at Sebastian's
murder
it's clear to me that Sebastian's wider
family in Poland will never forget him
and that his death is truly mourned
it is against this background that I now
turn to consider the appropriate
starting point for the sentence which I
must impose
as I've said the first question is
whether the correct starting point is
our whole life order
or a minimum term of 30 years
imprisonment before adjustment for any
aggravating or mitigating factors
for the purposes of this case paragraph
two of schedule 21 of the sentencing act
2020 provides that the appropriate
starting point is a whole life order
if the court considers the seriousness
of the murder to be exceptionally High
schedule 21 paragraph 2
subparagraph two of the sentencing act
2020 provides a non-exhaustive list of
cases or examples of cases which will
normally fall within the category
justifying a whole life term
the list includes the murder of a child
involved in the Abduction of the child
or sexual or sadistic motivation
the appropriate starting point is a term
of 30 years if the seriousness of the
offense is particularly High
paragraph three subparagraph two
provides that cases which will pay cases
which will normally fall within this
category
include a murder involving
sadistic conduct
a recent decision of the course of
appeal provides me with assistance on
the approach that I should take to
sentencing in this case
the court emphasized that all cases will
of course be fact specific
but it restated that even where a
mandatory life sentence is required
a whole life order is very rarely made
such a sentence is reserved for the few
exceptionally serious offenses in which
after reflecting on all the features of
aggravation and mitigation the judge is
satisfied that the element of just
punishment and retribution requires the
imposition of a whole life order
the course appeal continued by stating
this
that cases of murder involve taking a
human life where the offender intended
to kill
or cause really serious harm
all murders are necessarily extremely
serious crimes
and for that reason they attract the
mandatory life sentence
the requirement that the seriousness of
the offense must be exceptionally high
before a whole life order is made
therefore arises in that context
often where such an order is called for
the case will not be on the borderline
and the facts of the case considered as
a whole will leave the judge in No Doubt
that the offender must be kept in prison
for the rest of his or her own life
putting it starkly
the case must be exceptionally serious
even in the context of murder before a
whole life order is made
it's with this assistance and guidance
in mind therefore that I've therefore
considered whether the murder of
Sebastian kalanowski was of such
exceptional seriousness that the
starting point for sentence is our whole
life order
in my judgment none of the factors which
might normally in the words of schedule
21 lead to the imposition of a whole
life term or present I do not find that
the murder of Sebastian was motivated by
sadism
putting it another way I don't find that
either of you acted as you did towards
Sebastian because you took pleasure in
the pain or trauma reflected
clearly both of you must have been aware
of the pain that you're inflicting but
the true motivation certainly so far as
eulaterchefsky is concerned is I find
rather more complicated
as I've already said I find that your
abuse was motivated by the need to
dominate the need to control Sebastian
to the point almost of Oppression
in your case kalanaska
you just didn't care what happened to
Sebastian one way or another
you seemed oblivious
to the pain that you were inflicting
standing back
and taking into account all of those
factors which I must have in mind I am
not sure that this offense is one of
such exceptional seriousness as to
require me to take that starting point
of a whole life term
I therefore take 30 years as my starting
point for the minimum term which you
must serve both of you before
consideration is given to your release
by the parole board
I emphasize however
that the 30 years is simply the starting
point
I must take into account aggravating
factors and I must take into account
mitigating factors
and I recognize that the aggravating
factors might in theory
lead to the imposition of a whole life
term
alternatively even I even if I do not
impose a whole life order I recognize
that the effect of my sentence may be
the equivalent given your ages now
in this case there are a number of
powerful aggravating factors
one Sebastian's vulnerability
Sebastian was a young teenage boy who
spoke little if any English
he had neither friends nor allies in
this country
Sebastian was wholly dependent upon you
both for his well-being
he attended school where he encountered
teachers who were committed and who were
interested in him
but these events took place during the
time of covet
and there was for that reason little
continuity of attendance
two
the abuse of the relationship of trust
which should have existed between mother
and child and stepfather and child
three the length of the abuse starting
at the very latest in January 2021 and
continuing until his death
four the extent of the abuse involving
injuries to the Torso ribs heart lungs
to Serious muscle injuries to the thigh
and to the buttocks
five the extreme pain which you call
Sebastian and his very painful death
six your failure to seek hospital or
medical assistance in the few days
before his death when it would or should
it must have been apparent to you that
Sebastian was seriously ill from
infection
and finally your delay in calling the
Emergency Services after Sebastian's
collapse on the 13th of August
ewsky you are 38 years old colonoska you
are 36 years old neither of you has in
reality any mitigation
it's submitted on your behalf that
neither of you had the intention to kill
and I accept that I accept that had you
wished to kill him it would have been an
easy task for you to accomplish
but I consider this
to be of marginal and relevance given
the nature of the assaults which you
inflicted on Sebastian any one of which
could have resulted in fatal injury
I also bear in mind that you are not the
principal perpetrator of the physical
abuse
but I see you as a full and willing
participant in all that took place over
the course of Last Summer
you may not have hit Sebastian as often
as latachevsky did or as hard but by
your apps and words you encouraged him
in what he did and I make no token
adjustment to reflect the fact that you
are not the principal perpetrator of
this abuse
for the offense of Cruelty to a child
the maximum sentence which I can impose
is one of tenure's imprisonment
the sentence which I impose and respect
of this offense will be served
concurrently
I am told that you have both served 444
days on demand and that will be taken
into account and calculating the term of
imprisonment which you will each serve
if that figure is inaccurate then it can
be dealt with administratively
the victim's surcharge will apply
please stand up
for the murder of Sebastian Kalinowski
the sentence of the court is
imprisonment for life
I set the minimum term at 39 years
for the offense of Cruelty but to a
child the sentence is one of nine years
kalanowska for the murder of your son
Sebastian Kalinowski the sentence of the
court is imprisonment for life
I set the minimum term at 39 years
for the offense of Cruelty to a child
the sentence is one of nine years
thank you doc officers please take the
defendant